january 6 2021 were you in dc on that  day  yeah i was  and were you in the area of the capitol  yeah  did you go into the capital  no absolutely not you didn't  did you breach barricades  no you didn't  no  what was the extent of your presence  there  um we watched uh trump's speech  we walked we walked on the on the path  to uh  the capitol building and then um  now in in in retrospect um there were  some  wind fences that were that were up but  you know we weren't aware of that by the  time we got there and uh when we did get  to the the capitol building um within i  don't know 10 minutes 15 minutes uh  capitol police  started to  engage the crowd and so um everybody  that i was with we just  we left you left at that point yeah  absolutely